c'est au moins tu veux pas y avait son
bras c'est dommage tout cas un cintre
même sachant que votre bassin et mobile
et que le crâne de bébé n'est pas encore
soudées il peut passer facilement garder
on aspire en bloc et on expire voilà il
le jour de l'accouchement
vous allez expiré en poussant donc on
recommence on inspire on bloque gens
poussent comme si on allait à la selle
pas de honte
on ouvre les failles fin vous savez
quatre femmes sur cinq font le jour de
l'accouchement
c'est normal imaginez un tube de
dentifrice
si vous marchez dessus alors qu'il est
plein le dentifrice va sortir des
questions oui moi j'aurais voulu savoir
par rapport à la douleur
en fait oui on nous a dit sans
péridurale
ben c'est comme si on ne te péter les
côtés moi je fais pas de péridurale
ils peuvent te rater et sectionné la
moelle épinière et vaucluse et moi est
ce qu'on peut parler de l'épisiotomie
s'il vous plaît parce que j'ai une amie
donc ça suffit à coucher c'est la chose
la plus naturelle au monde c'est clair
l'espace aubry n'a
sabrina et des jumelles un dernière elle
remet ça tellement ça lui a plu c'était
le plus beau jour de ma vie
exactement et a pas eu mal c'est que du
bonheur
et et a accouché dans quelle position
c'est quelques bonnes merci sabrina on
va aller visiter la salle d'accouchement
maintenant vous voulez voir des nouveaux
nés
e
oui
[Musique]
écoutez moi je vous dise
c'était mon sens
chrome os ne sais quoi qu'est ce qui se
passe ici c'est que du bonheur
[Musique]
vous la fermer ou ne vous inquiétez pas
tout va bien voilà entrés tient sa
première réunion est important
coucou ces vidéos ça va c'était bien
votre trépas l'accouchement c'est que du
bonheur ouais c'est que du bonheur c'est
ça va mieux c'était c'était bd c'est que
du bonheur ouais je vous en fait je vous
les laisse là
[Musique]
comme avant